back in 2017 Marlene King introduced
fans of The Pretty Little Liars show to
a spin-off series called the
perfectionist
welcome to Beacon Heights University
where excellence is not an option it's a
requirement
this one fans of the show and the books
into a frenzy with everybody asking a
ton of questions well any of the cast be
returning will we get another story
revolving around the infamous a what can
we expect from the plot and will ariana
grande actually be making an appearance
for all the answers to those questions
and more be sure to keep on watching hey
guys it's your host Noir and welcome
back to the things before we get started
don't forget to subscribe like and turn
on those post notifications let's start
off today's video with a shout out to
our awesome things member fizzy pop I
definitely spotted you as the first
commenter on our zoey valentine video
and the things loves you too
the last episode of Pretty Little Liars
aired almost two years ago back in 2017
so it's definitely been a while since
you've seen some of our favorite
actresses not to worry though because
Lorna and Allie will be back on our
screens with the spin-off the
perfectionist set to air in June of 2019
did you miss me Carrie Burke the EVP of
the production company has said that she
cannot wait to continue Marlene Kings
rich and revolutionary way of
storytelling with a new crop of leading
ladies who will hold just as many lies
as rosewood did Marlon King has also
said that she cannot wait to introduce
fans to a new world of grills and chills
in Beacon Heights King was heavily
involved in the writing process of the
upcoming show's pilot and will even be
producing it alongside some of our
favorite producers who brought us some
vintage worthy television series like
The Vampire Diaries the originals and
even the 100 the series will include 10
episodes for the first season and here's
what the plot tells us so far everything
about the town of beacon Heights seems
perfect from their overachieving
residents to their talk to your college
but nothing in Beacon Heights is as it
appears to be all the stress of being
perfect leads to the town's first murder
behind every perfectionist is a secret
ally and a needed alibi I've been in
your shoes what are you gonna do
nothing I haven't done before King also
gives us a ton of hints about the plot
since just like the original Pretty
Little Liars we can't really depend on
the books for too much solid information
she mentions that the perfectionist will
be pretty similar to the Pretty Little
Liars since there is a big mystery a
murder and a fracture group of people
who become friends through murder one of
the more interesting details that she
gives us is that the show will introduce
four new characters with one plot twist
one of them will not even be making it
to the end of the show's pilot you
should know a student was murdered
everybody a phe was a suspect we also
won't need to go through seven seasons
to understand Alison and Mona's roles in
the show since we'll all apparently make
sense after the first episode as for the
perfectionist the first of them will be
played by Sophia Carson who you guys
might recognize from The Descendants
movies she'll be playing Ava Jalali a
trend-setting blogger and coder who
strives to be a fashion icon
the second perfectionist is Kaitlyn who
will be played by Sidney part Kaitlyn is
a smart and driven perfect daughter of
two perfect mothers she aspires to
follow in her mother's political
footsteps and even start a political
career of her own the third character to
enter the Stepford Wives themed
nightmare is Dylan who will be played by
Eli Brown his character is described as
a gifted cellist who is very competitive
and reward driven his passion for music
is only second to his passion for his
boyfriend save it for somebody who
believes what you say you're hot when
you're angry
other characters include Mason who will
be an athletic-type college student who
attends beacon Heights University I
don't want to use this I will if I have
to
aside from a few other interesting
characters we can probably expect the
shoulder evolved around college students
instead of high schoolers since it was
mentioned that there is a top-tier
college and Beacon Heights this would be
pretty perfect for Allison's character
since the transition from a high school
teacher in the book to make college
professor in the show would be a pretty
smooth one as for Mona we did see her
make a big move to Paris at the season
finale of Pretty Little Liars this tells
me that there is something awfully
special about Beacon Heights that lures
her away from her new
life of Berets and creepy dolls thank
you Tom mana where were you when me was
killed what kind of person do you think
I am well all the stock of Beacon
Heights makes me pretty curious as to
where it is like geographically this
piece of info is pretty important since
it's going to have huge implications for
Alison's relationships and the season
finale of Pretty Little Liars it's not
only did we see Alison and Emily in a
loving relationship but they also
decided to raise Alison's twins together
back in Rosewood
I want to do this together and now for
our final scoop of the video will ariana
grande really be making an appearance
since Romero spotted on Instagram but
for now is still just a rumor I'm Ren or
and for more videos like this one don't
forget to subscribe to the things give
this video a big thumbs up and hit me up
on Instagram see you guys next time
[Music]